[Applause]
[Applause]
oh boy
yeah it's weird what do we do
you know what i can get into that i like
it that's the first time i've ever done
that oh well i like the butt bump i got
a lot of butt so you know
i don't have to travel very far i don't
know what i was drawn in i was like
i loved it my butt has a mind of its own
too i mean that's the best thing to have
a butt that wants to wander exactly you
know well speaking of your butt wandered
right onto something
that has become your new hobby i don't
know where you found time for a hobby
with your schedule but tell us what it
is because i'm so into it ooh are you
talking about pole dancing yes
i
love it i i think it's fun and i've
heard you've gotten even more flexible
like this is not a recent pick you're
even more bendy oh yeah i can slam it
right into the ground uh
i could do like a drop right in there
and it's like pretty flat how
how
a lot of stretching a lot of hopes and a
lot of dreams
and what like inspired
what was the thing that catalyst the
moment where you're like i'm gonna do
this um
going to a strip club and being like
these women are athletes
like they're so athletic and it's so
amazing to watch them do it they're also
great actresses they're like i like you
and you're like that's an act um
he's okay you know i love you everybody
needs like more humor and awesomeness
like you
um and also i want to get into your
podcast why
won't you date me yes okay what was the
origin story to starting this podcast
okay so like i'm a single woman and i
was like why won't they date me
maybe if i ask i'll get an answer right
and know
you know it's cheaper than therapy you
know
and
like also great outreach maybe lucrative
you get to play with fun people you have
amazing comedians on the show
and
okay
what have you learned okay because i
want to learn too i'm like fascinated i
love this podcast who doesn't want to
ask these questions
i'm single i hooked right into this i
was like tell me everything
um okay here's what i've learned i mean
have i really learned i'm still single
you know but um well that's what you
think but i think i'm good at
relationships i'm single i understand
relationships i think i and we can all
help other people more than ourselves
let's face it i guess yeah if you can't
do teach is that the saying something
like that those who can't teach which is
insane to say you know it's like you
suck at this go teach it but
anyway i've learned to like not dim my
light that like i am a lot and whoever
is going to love me is going to accept
that i am doing the
most um
and then
also
what a mean trick that would be if up
front i was like hi i'm normal and then
a couple months in i'm like
and they're like yikes i don't know this
woman um i've also learned that like you
got to ask for what you want like if you
want to be in a relationship you have to
be upfront be like that's what i want
from you you know it's true there it's i
loved that you said don't let them dim
your light
so many of us um because i'm a lot too
like i i
i have a big life i have a big
personality
like i've been single for years oh it's
a lot by choice
a lot because
it's just really hard it might be hard
you're very famous and it must like
intimidate the gentleman they must be
like i don't know will i stack up to her
and it's like well if you're worrying
about that you're worrying about the
wrong thing you know what i mean and
also like don't we worry that that's our
friends saying that to make us feel
better to find an excuse of why we're
all really single because i it can't be
that like men cannot function that way
that isn't attractive i don't know i've
dated a lot of men and the way they
function done makes sense
[Music]